mientras el mundo Mira atónito las
imágenes de la toma del Capitolio a
principios de 2021 la crisis en Estados
Unidos copa las portadas del mundo
[Música]
pocos meses después Rusia despliega
alrededor de 20.000 soldados a tan solo
100 kilómetros de la frontera con
Ucrania en la que es considerada la
movilización más numerosa desde que
estalló el conflicto en 2014 Washington
hizo saltar las alarmas
estamos profundamente preocupados por la
evidencia de que Rusia ha hecho planes
para movimientos agresivos
significativos contra Ucrania en
diciembre de 2021 Rusia pidió una serie
de garantías de seguridad a Estados
Unidos
sin trucos lo decimos muy claramente no
debería haber una expansión de la otan
hacia el este la pelota está en su campo
necesitan darnos alguna respuesta
los servicios de inteligencia
estadounidenses avisan que Rusia planea
Elevar su presencia militar hasta los
175 mil soldados en la frontera con
Ucrania con el potencial objetivo de
invadir el país a principios de 2022 la
mayoría de europeos viajan a Moscú e
intentan persuadir a Vladimir Putin para
que detenga sus planes
decía que Estados Unidos advierte cada
vez con más vehemencia que una invasión
rusa es inminente
Moscú niega repetidamente las
afirmaciones de Washington
nuestros militares se desplegaron
tranquilamente en su propio territorio
realizaron ejercicios militares luego
empacaron sus tiendas cargaron el equipo
sobre rieles y comenzaron a irse pero la
histeria continúa
[Música]
el 21 de febrero los líderes de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas de doníes y
lugans solicitan al presidente Putin que
reconozca sus independencias
creo que es necesario tomar una decisión
largamente esperada reconocer de
inmediato la independencia y la
soberanía de la República Popular de
dones y la República Popular de lugano
tras el anuncio de Putin la Unión
Europea acuerda por unanimidad paquete
de sanciones a Rusia al día siguiente el
pentágono vuelve a alertar sobre la
posibilidad de un ataque inminente y
advierte que Rusia ya tiene desplegados
en la frontera con Ucrania a más de
200.000 soldados tambores de guerra
suenan nuevamente en Europa